oh yeah wow that's cool
and you can just uh keep golfing huh
[Music]
all right that guy's going in the pool a
party goer
goer dive bombs into the pool causing a
splash
the elderly woman believes she can walk
on water
a little boy pushes the groom into the
pool that's it see
let's see it come on kid knock that guy
into the pool
come on oh my god
please oh why did you not see the water
how can you not see that
what do you ladies say the little child
says i hate children
or i pissed myself or fancy a brew love
i'm gonna go with uh fancy a brew love
that's what old people say what do
ladies say
i piss myself
i love it kids say the darndest things
now look at this little dolly
getting married because they won't get
married what to do when you get married
you stay stuck together until you die
you live happily ever after
see one of the girls makes a confusing
gesture
i'm going to say this little girl's wise
beyond her years
and she says you stay stuck together
till you die
they pretended they didn't know what it
was she was doing
very smart what are you doing there
don't give anything away
the golfer accidentally strikes his
friends back with the golf ball
some angry kangaroos have a fist fight
the ball bounces off a wall and hits the
golfer in
the balls well that
i'm not going to go with balls we've
seen it been there done that
let's go with some angry kangaroos
having a fist fight
oh yeah wow that's cool
that's like wild
and you can just uh keep golfing huh
oh is that person to sleep hey the
trickster
gets tackled onto his sleeping friend
causing the towering furniture to
collapse
b the sofa bed collapses and engulfs the
trickster
the guy sleeping under the furniture
lets out a terrifying scream i'm going
to say it's three and i'm also going to
uh quibble with the reference of the
dip friend being referenced as a
trickster
ah idiot
got what he deserved fire hydrant
love it another pipe bursts just in
front of the camera causing the phone to
launch into the air and land on the roof
the burst pipe suddenly starts spraying
towards the crowd causing chaotic alarm
see a man launches himself onto the
burst pipe causing him to fly upwards
yes
of course it's c i'm gonna guess there's
a drunk person walking around
who decides to be a hero and his drunken
logic backfires
not the first time that's happened let's
close that close the hole
do it hero there you go superman
concussion by request
i'm bob odenkirk that was what happens
next
for lad bible
oh no you didn't no no no no that's that
is not fair
that's not fair because what you said
the option was a dog sits on a head
no what happened there was a dog
teabagged
that was remarkable